monsieur et puis le bord bonjour merci
d'être en direct sur arte france alors
on vient de me dire le président
brésilien ou encore le maire de new york
mais aussi en france le professeur raoul
tu ont fait l'objet d'un contrôle accru
de leur publication sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que c'est de la censure
de la modération à votre avis
objectivement il s'agit là d'éléments de
langage sur le fond c'est à peu près la
même chose
après on a une situation très
particulière avec facebook en ce moment
du simple fait que ses armées
modérateurs sont dans la même situation
que moi ils sont en confinement dons qui
sont pas en mesure de travailler donc
l'aîné la capacité de modérer de
facebook est très très lourdement
affecté par le confinement et on a
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui fonctionne
entre une équipe qui doit être
extrêmement réduit et des algorithmes
qui ne sont pas du tout fait pour être
autonome et pour fonctionner tout seul
avec évidemment à droite à gauche
en france par exemple avec tous ceux de
toute cette controverse sur la
chloroquine et le rôle que prend le
professeur à ou dans le débat public et
surtout les centaines de milliers de
fans sur facebook qui se regroupent qui
conteste qui protège qui partagent des
informations on a une situation
totalement explosé tout à fait similaire
à celle d'un gilet jaune au tout début
du phénomène des jv jaune donc forcément
on a très certainement une volonté de
calmer le jeu à travers de la modération
qui ne pouvons pas s'exécuter de façon
parfaite peau de personnel donne
énormément d'effets de bord mais ça
c'était tout à fait prévisible à partir
du moment où fait de la modération sur
facebook en fonction d'une loi nationale
vous allez forcément avoir beaucoup
beaucoup déplorent récemment ursula von
der leyen la présidente de la commission
européenne a indiqué que l'union
européenne travailler main dans la main
avec les réseaux sociaux pour mettre en
avant les sources officielles et ce que
l'on peut parler d'une censure organisé
avec l'europe dont on peut parler d'une
tentative pour l'europe de reprendre la
main sur l'opinion publique des
populations européennes essaient des
tentatives qui sont d'une part assez
maladroite et puis d'autre part on peut
vraiment se demander si facebook est en
mesure de proposer ça où l'europe et
même si elle en a un intérêt stratégique
si on considère que facebook est un
acteur géopolitique aujourd'hui c'est
pas une entreprise il faut regarder les
choses en face
facebook a un statut qui est un hybride
entre eux une entreprise d'animation
cette une
territoire à part entière dont les états
aujourd'hui tels que la france estime
devoir non pas réguler un morceau du
territoire mais au contraire déléguer
leur capacité de réguler l'arc cette
justice a fait donc on est face à un
véritable pays d'un homme d'une forme
nouvelle api qui est le plus grand plus
d'utilisateurs de facebook que
d'habitants en chine et il va falloir
faire la police évidemment les instances
qu'elle soit l'europe ou des pays ont
envie de peser mais comme elles ont à
leur tête du personnel politique qui
comprend pas non plus très bien comment
tout ça fonctionne ça ne marche pas à
votre avis est-ce que ce genre de
pratique peu alimenté la défiance
vis-à-vis des médias dits de masse
aujourd'hui
bien sûr bien sûr d'autant plus que la
plupart du temps il faut être honnête
quand vous avez notamment tous déçus du
monde et gilet jaune mais de celui ci
aussi des plaintes et pour des
tentatives de censure
on a souvent affaire en fait à des gens
qui ne comprennent pas les principes de
base de facebook qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils peuvent pas partager ta les
mandants tel groupe
alors qu'il s'agit de restriction
naturel imposé typiquement par les gens
qui ont publié contenu donc il ya certes
évidemment de la modération de la
censure c'est vraiment une question de
point de vue mais aussi beaucoup
d'incompréhension sur l'outil tout ça
génère énormément de frustration et tout
ça le fait dans un contexte de colère
énorme contre le gouvernement que ce
soit en france en espagne et dans bien
d'autres pays
la plupart des gouvernements sont dans
des situations très tendues avec leurs
populations et la france provoquant dans
la situation la pire qui soit en europe
elle est partie avec un capital de
confiance pour leur politique était déjà
extrêmement bas et même le rebond qui a
donné la crise n'est pas suffisant pour
faire passer le président macron dans
une zone de confort on va dire où ils
auraient au moins la moitié de la
population tu ferais confiance mais on
en n'est même pas là et nos débuts du
peaufinement donc c'est très mal pas
très bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
monsieur fabrice était loin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur à
sciences po et spécialiste des médias
sociaux